y vamos a repasar el concepto de banco
de reserva y después vamos a platicar
acerca de la oferta de dinero elástica o
sea que el dinero crezca o disminuya
según la economía lo necesite bueno para
esto déjame crear pues unos cuantos
bancos así normales y comerciales vamos
a llamarle bancos nacionales pero bueno
supongamos que empezamos con una cierta
cantidad de capital y parte de ese
capital de hecho casi todo es oro
entonces ahí tenemos cierto oro con lo
cual capitalizamos el banco y además
teníamos un edificio bueno ponemos un
edificio va ahora supongamos que
recibimos algunos depósitos de no sé lo
que sea granjeros que acaban de tener su
cosecha algo así y pues también tengo
que poner un pasivo correspondiente voy
a ponerlo en color azul y son cuentas de
cheques este es de un granjero es la
cuenta de un granjero vamos a poner que
sólo son dos granjeros entonces esa es
otra cuenta
ahora aprendimos en el sistema de banca
con reserva fraccionaria que podemos
tener un cierto apalancamiento con una
cantidad dada de reservas siempre y
cuando tengamos un coeficiente mínimo
entre esas reservas y la cantidad de
pasivo exigible que tenemos entonces
supongamos que el coeficiente de reserva
en este mundo desde este
como no quiero que quede muy alto vamos
a ponerle que es de 50% en la vida real
es como de 10% pero bueno déjame
escribir que en este mundo el
coeficiente de reserva debe de ser 50%
va eso quiere decir que la razón entre
oro y depósitos exigibles aquí al
instante no puede ser menor al 50% para
entonces cualquier cantidad que sea
puedo duplicarla en términos de cuentas
de cheques va entonces esto nos vamos a
ponerle por aquí que en total tengo 100
en oro de tal forma que puedo tener
hasta 200 digamos que hasta ahorita aquí
tenemos 50 en depósitos entonces puedo
tener hasta 200 en cuentas va entonces
puedo prestar dinero para crear cuentas
de depósitos y bueno todo esto es un
repaso verdad espero que quien nada más
sea un repaso para ti entonces puedo
prestar hasta 150 más puedo prestar 150
abriendo cuentas de cheques vamos a
hacer que se vea muy bonito que se vea
súper en limpio
y entonces de este lado tenemos los
activos verdad ya tengo un préstamo que
haga esto es el préstamo esa es la
cuenta correspondiente verdad entonces
otra vez tenemos este préstamos un
préstamo más grande etcétera
ahora resulta que no sea el único banco
en este universo déjame copiar y pegar
este banco de aquí control de control ve
ahí está lo voy a poner por ahí este es
otro banco en el universo quiero
mostrarte cómo puede haber más de un
banco
dirigimos que había algunos problemas
con esto ya tenemos un coeficiente de
reserva de 50 por ciento que es muy alto
pero qué tal que por alguna razón súper
rara las reservas pues bajan de 50 por
ciento como enlaces para obtener el oro
adicional no quiere decir a la gente que
te espere tantito porque se van a
espantar y va a hacer que se caiga el
sistema pero si estás un poquito abajo
de 50 y el otro banco está tantito
arriba de 50 entonces a lo mejor le
puedes pedir prestado al otro banco
verdad o mejor aún si hubiera un
depósito central donde todo el oro
estuviera entonces tú simplemente
podrías ir a ese depósito central y
tomar prestado si no hubiera otro banco
que tuviera oro verdad entonces puedes
pensarlo como un recurso de emergencia
en nuestro vídeo nos meteremos un poco
más en la mecánica precisa de esto con
eso dicho vamos a crear un banco de
reserva donde ponemos todo este oro va
todos estos que son 200 si verdad 100 y
100 200 déjame copiarlos y pegarlos
entonces vamos a poner todos esos 200
sabes
a ésta le voy a dar copiar
esa es una de las reservas como la otra
era igual más le voy pegar hay está muy
bien ahí está ya se ve bonito y pues
bueno todos los bancos se reunieron es
un banco privado después vamos a hablar
un poquito acerca de cómo funciona así
en la vida real en fin entonces esto de
aquí sería el oro que respalda o sea
serían las reservas de oro entonces
déjame pasarlos un poco a la izquierda
porque como es el oro del banco central
ahora se convierte en un activo verdad
para el banco central déjame poner esto
en negro está muy bien y el pasivo
correspondiente para este banco de
reserva central voy a hacer los pasivos
por acá la derecha los voy a hacer con
un rectángulo en color rojo
entonces el pasivo son las cuentas de
cheques para estos bancos de aquí
entonces como este banco pues depositó
su oro en el banco central a cambio
ahora tiene una cuenta de cheques en
este banco central
y vamos a suponer por simplicidad que en
vez de tener una cuenta de cheques
obtuvo notas bancarias de la reserva
federal o sea billetes pues entonces
supongamos que sexo oro se convirtió en
poner aquí en color verde vamos a
ponerle 100 notas bancarias pendientes
con otras bancarias pendientes
corresponde a este banco y acá arriba
estas 100 notas claro verdad el problema
con las notas bancarias es que no
sabemos de quién son realmente a
diferencia de las cuentas de cheques
verdad pero bueno notas bancarias
pendientes para entonces esencialmente
el banco de arriba en vez de tener oro
ahora tiene estas notas bancarias de la
reserva federal que son verdes y esto se
convierte en su reserva su reserva ya no
es oro verdad su reserva es cuántas de
estas en otras bancarias tiene igual acá
abajo verdad está en verde y ya vimos
que sólo el banco central puede emitir
estas notas bancarias
únicamente el banco federal puede emitir
los 80 elige federal pero bueno creo que
ya ves a dónde se dirige esto
las notas bancarias son así son piezas
rectangulares con caras de presidentes
lo que sea y tiene algunos numeritos y
son infalsificables va ahora supongamos
que en el gobierno de que vivimos este
pase en una multa o sea supongamos que
esté acá es es una institución privada
ahora el gobierno le pone ciertas reglas
a esta institución de modo que aunque
muchos bancos lo capitalicen con su
dinero estos bancos no reciban interés
por sus depósitos después nos vamos a
meter más en las dinámicas de los bancos
centrales de países desarrollados pero
su pero por el momento vamos a pensar
que las ganancias de este banco
simplemente van al gobierno federal
entonces los bancos no ganan intereses
por su dinero en el banco central
supongamos que además no se la mesa
directiva del banco también es elegida
por el gobierno lo cual es clave para
que funcione nuestro sistema financiero
entonces como ves el gobierno está
metidísimo además se da cuenta que el
banco emite esta nota bancaria que todo
el mundo usa y entonces quiere que la
gente tenga fe mucha fe en esa moneda
para que la gente pueda tener fe así
ilimitada en la moneda entonces lo que
hace
es decidir que él va a respaldar la
moneda qué quiere decir esto
antes déjame escribirlo esto es algo que
me confundía muchísimo las notas están
emitidas emitidas por el banco de
reservas de reserva sin embargo es una
obligación una obligación del gobierno
del gobierno va ahora qué quiere decir
eso bueno eso quiere decir que si por
alguna razón aunque a este banco de
reserva se le acabe su oro o sea si la
gente viene pide el oro y no lo tiene
este incluso en ese caso el gobierno y
el gobierno tiene la responsabilidad de
darte el oro correspondiente a estas
notas bancarias no sea al cambio que
decidimos no se 35 billetes por onza de
oro o lo que sea esto y justo esto es lo
que le da muchísima confianza a la gente
de que estos papelitos son tan buenos
como el oro ahora porque esto le daría
tanta confianza de la gente en la moneda
pues resulta que el gobierno puede poner
impuestos y entonces puede ponerle
impuestos a las personas en dinero
en oro o en bienes y servicios y bueno
siempre y cuando la gente piense que la
economía está bien que el gobierno si
puede gobernar de manera razonable para
responder por eso verdad si creen que el
gobierno puede que esté respaldar este
papelito entonces tú puedes creer que es
tan bueno como el oro va bueno con eso
dicho vamos a introducir la noción de
esta oferta elástica no mejor antes de
eso deja de ver una cosa más que tiene
que ver con esto entonces ya dijimos que
es una obligación del gobierno verdad lo
cual quiere decir que si todo falla
entonces el gobierno es responsable de
pagar por esas notas bancarias voy a
introducir otro concepto que es muy
similar a estas notas bancarias y es
deuda de gobierno o un préstamo
gubernamental déjame describirlo por
aquí abajo creo que se me está acabando
el tiempo bueno seguir en el siguiente
vídeo si se me acaba entonces yo soy el
gobierno yo como gobierno me activo es
mi capacidad de crear impuestos ahora si
yo soy el gobierno y evito estos pagarés
déjame ponerle por aquí pagaré de
gobierno como le pondremos
y bonos pagarés y pagarés pagarés del
gobierno
en general podemos pensar los como
instrumentos financieros del tesoro
recuerda que la diferencia entre letras
y bonos es que letras es a corto plazo y
bonos a largo plazo ahorita no me quiero
meter mucho con esos detalles después lo
hacemos con más calma pero por el
momento llamémosle pagarés ahora los
pagarés del gobierno son considerados
como libres de riesgo porque son
considerados libres de riesgo número uno
porque están denominados en la misma
moneda que el gobierno utiliza es la
misma moneda que emite el banco central
y dos veces o sea si este gobierno que
lo puedes pensar como el gobierno de un
país desarrollado como eeuu si el
gobierno te pide prestado entonces te da
un pagaré este soy yo esté aquí es el
gobierno
entonces si me da este pagaré y yo le
doy al gobierno pues no sé 100 dólares
por decir algo va si yo le doy cien
dólares verdad voy a poner en color
verde en color dólares porque sé que
este pagaré está libre de riesgo porque
digo que es libre de riesgo
sabes porque a menos que el gobierno
haga un error así terrible terrible que
empieza a prestar muchísimo con osea
interés bajo y que haga las cosas súper
mal entonces sabes que el gobierno
siempre puede hacer más impuestos para
obtener esos 100 dólares y pagarte los
entonces este de aquí este pagaré lo
podemos pensar como libre de riesgo con
esto en mente cuando el gobierno sale y
dice y saben que quiero hacer una nueva
guerra o no sé quiero hacer un puente
quiero hacer un nuevo esquema
burocrático pues es muy fácil que la
gente salga y diga sí sí yo te presto yo
te voy a prestar de mi dinero ya que la
gente acepta le da al gobierno sus
billetes sus billetes de dólares o de
pesos a cambio el gobierno le da un
pagaré que pues estamos diciendo que es
libre de riesgo y ya con el dinero el
gobierno puede comprar armas o hacer el
puente o hacer el esquema burocrático
que quiera sale y vale en el siguiente
vídeo vamos a ver cómo le puede hacer
este banco este banco de la reserva
central para comprar y vender pagarés de
gobierno de modo que pueda aumentar o
disminuir la oferta de dinero según los
la economía nos vemos